how do you write good dialogue
i think the best dialogue comes from the
best listeners
um i had an absolute
crash course in writing dialogue years
ago i used to write with charlie sheen
um i don't care if they don't credit him
and the sitcoms he's been in as a writer
i know who's been writing the dialogue i
worked with him for three years
i i never read or heard better dialogue
from anybody than that came from him
that he wrote
and i asked him one day i used to be
really good at writing scene direction
my dialogue was flat
it wasn't interesting it wasn't engaging
it was an edgy or seat
and i asked him one day when we were
writing
the way we worked is we'd set it up and
i would write the scene direction and he
would do the dialogue unless you know it
was some basic stuff it was easy and
i finally said to him i said where do
you get this
encyclopedia of incredible dialogue i've
never heard anybody with it before
and he said you just listen he said
you know when this was working these
aren't working
and if these aren't working you can't
absorb what's happening and how people
interact and find those gems he said
most
most of the things that i write that
people like i heard at a party i heard
at a barbecue i heard at an airport i
heard
while i was pumping gas he said you know
i'll get out and pump gas
and i'll hear a couple bickering in the
car next to me at the pump
and he said that's gold he goes that is
gold man he said you know and this is
before everybody had phones so we were
we weren't listening to them we were
doing this
so i find the best
the best advice to writing good dialogue
is listen put yourself in a character's
position that you've created
you know it goes back to the old um i
think
keeping an audience interested in good
dialogue i think
also the problem is a lot of people try
to outwit themselves with dialogue
they think they've got to use verbage or
words that people don't use
they got to show you how smart they are
i think we've talked about it before
it's like the drummer that overplays
everything to show
look how good my chops are and it's not
about that
it's it's about it's about
making things sound organic and that's a
lot of things that the actors have to
understand too is you know they're
acting or are they
truly listening and responding with the
work
but i think the best dialogue comes from
the best listeners and the people that
know how to implement those words that
they've discovered over the years and
new
and new arenas i mean obviously you're
not going to be pumping gas at a gas
station and hear a husband and wife
every script you write is not going to
be about a husband and wife pumping gas
at a gas
station so where else can you implement
that could that be a film like sahara
where matthew mcconaughey and
penelope cruz are walking across the
desert or you can put some of that
bickering in in different situations but
it's it's how you use it how it inspires
you to go down different paths
that's how i've i i learned from him to
to
write better dialogue i'm still not very
good but i know
i i know good dialogue when i hear it
and i'm good at adjusting dialogue when
i get it
and i it's about listening and now
people are on phones
so you can just hear one side or one
side and i don't think people realize or
they care
how well you can hear them and how
dialed in everybody no pun intended to
the people are
to what i mean i've heard some major
arguments major personal
and i'm like i don't think this person
realizes i can hear them halfway across
the store
but that's gold too it's gold and it's
even better when they're
when they're on speaker phones so you do
get to hear all of it or they're the
receiver's up so loud but you're right i
mean sometimes you'll hear one half of
the conversation and sometimes that
could be
better because you're able to imagine i
mean can you imagine if it was hey
harold you didn't take the trash barrels
and that's what the whole fight's about
but you're only hearing harold's side
can you imagine what you can create mod
is yelling
to him about i mean
when you were working at the car lot
did it did you pick up anything about
dialogue i realized that's not why you
were there
but if i'm coming to look at a car
you know i'm probably going to be
hesitant i'm probably going to be like i
don't want this guy to sell me anything
but i do need a car but i don't want to
let him know that
sure so i'm going to be very selective
with what i say
um i learned um as i said when the owner
of galpin had said come sell cars he
said you'll learn more about life than
you've ever
known and it'll be the education that
you lacked he wasn't he wasn't
kidding you become a good listener
because you have to overcome all
objectives you have to address every
concern and need that a customer has so
how does that happen it happens by
listening
and i always i it wasn't dialogue
lines i don't think and i have a very
retentive memory if i hear something i
remember it
um there wasn't anything said
in those 18 months i worked there that
stood out but it was
mannerisms it was quirks it was
character flaws or
or neat things about
people that i that i still to this day
will implement in my characters
um the way a husband and wife interact
it's not about what's said it's about
how it's said it's about the posture
it's about um
the the 45 year old son who's with the
70 year old parents buying the ford
taurus today
and you realize the parents have a
gambling addiction they're getting a car
to drive to vegas every other week but
the 45 year old son still lives at home
to help supplement the
the overhead so they can afford to
maintain their lifestyle and the kids
kind of a deadbeat too i mean
there's all sorts of and you look at
that and you go well that's that's a
story
you know you got this retired this
retired milkman and his wife who ran a
salon and now they
are addicted to going to vegas every
well what else are they doing when they
go to vegas that we don't know about you
know
and then your minds are what do they see
on that trip to vegas um
you know it's the the lotto winners i
sold i sold to a few lotto winners
that was interesting i actually had a
salesman i worked with
who had won 24 million dollars in the
big
lotto and he left his wife and
two and a half years later he was at the
point selling cars with me
and you want to talk about like having
it all and losing it and you know
friends who
abandoned him when the money was gone
and he said yeah you know it's funny my
wife still has her 10 million
you know and here i am selling cars
trying to make trying to make a living
living in a one-bedroom apartment you
know and
he was the one who left her and was
horrible to her yeah
you see a whole bunch of really
interesting people
um but that two years sorry to interrupt
but that two years
was probably very fascinating it was
fascinating uh as i said i'm still very
close to the family that
that gifted me that opportunity the
bachmanns
i am still very close to some of the
salesmen that i worked with a lot you
know sadly some of them have perished um
you know some of the people that were in
that sales class i took patrick wellman
just died six months ago i found out and
stuart sank who sold with me and i got
the most
character stories out of the anybody in
the world
passed uh these would be what i worked
with and i i was very close to and
it was amazing just the people the
experiences the
the encounters of just walking out
having a cigarette and encountering a
guy whose car is in for an oil change
and that 20-minute exchange you have
with this guy those conversations will
live with you forever
but you don't have to sell cars to do it
you can you can
drive an uber you can work at a
restaurant as a waiter you can work
anywhere
most of the encounters that i've had in
my life that i write about are about
personal experiences or exchanges or
encounters that i've had
anywhere but it's funny you bring up the
car years because that was my job five
six days a week i'd spent those eight to
12 hours a day
at the dealership dealing with no two
days were over the same
fighting between you know salesmen for a
customer
or a customer you know there's an old
saying and buying cars is all buyers are
liars
and it was about trying to i learned
something we used to have a salesman
there that sold
ungodly amounts of cars and made ungodly
amounts of money
and i used to say to him what's your
secret and he says you just got to
remember all buyers are liars
and they're telling you one thing
because they think they can have an edge
and the
secret to successfully selling cars is
giving buyers
they got to trust you they got to like
you and want to deal with you but he
said
you have to let them think they have
control but they really don't have an
ounce of it and it's almost like being a
film director
actors love to be directed and
controlled
but they also like to think that they
they're the show they're the as a good
director will help steer them and let
them think that they can run with it
and you've got to be able to rein them
in without them knowing they're being
reined in
it's an art it's a dance and it's that
way selling cars
um but it taught me how to negotiate um
selling cars and negotiating
four five six times a day sure taught me
how to go out and raise money sure
taught me how to negotiate
with contracts and actors and agents
it's the same thing how much for how
much
right so that's
everybody should go sell cars and you'll
become a better filmmaker
you